[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so verließ
welt uns ist heute nach einer eistorte
und ich hatte kurz überlegt ob ich nicht
einen ukas eistorte machen soll was ja
schon ich schon ziemlich gigantisch
gewesen wäre aber dann hab ich was sie
beim kühlschrank entdeckt und bin so
rohr
ich mache meine kinder bueno eistorte
ganz ohne packen und die torte die wird
der hammer super einfach in der
herstellung dekoration überlege ich mir
noch geschmack wird der hammer ich
verwende dafür denn zuerst mache ich
halt die creme 250 gramm passt ab ohne
acht kinder bueno 250 gramm sahne etwas
seiner partnerstadt schlagen und
butterkekse richter jetzt zuerst die
kinder erinnern als es eigentlich
solltet ihr neuen nehmen denn einen
könnt ihr aber ich bin nicht so die nach
stadt von problem ist viel so ich freue
mich einfach später auf ein stück vor
das kommt jetzt hier in der schiffe okay
was ich sagen muss ich echt ein bisschen
verpackungs alarm also da finde ich ein
bisschen schade dass die alle einzeln
gepackt sind vor allem glaube ich liebte
jeder wohnung das heißt man kann es hier
im prinzip auch in mehrwegverpackungen
machen und ich will bitte er betonen ich
mache keine werbung für die firma kinder
ich muss keine werbung für sich gemacht
ich bin jetzt einfach mal was guckt und
ich bekomme nichts dafür
ich habe kinder plätze frei
vielleicht werde ich irgendwann kapieren
und einfach ein finder wo immer selber
machen wenn ja schreibt gerne in die
kommentare
da war ein blick sagt schon alles
schreibt sind die kommentare wenn wir
ein xxl kinder bueno machen sollen
lecker und ich mache noch eine kinder
bueno torte denn das wurde schon lange
lange lange gewünscht so musste also
dass wir nicht echt schade dass alles
für ein plastik in vielen verpackungen
verpackt ist aber halt so lebensmittel
und jetzt nehmt ihr einfach irgendwas
zum zerstampfen so ganz brutal so könnte
auch mitzunehmen
[Musik]
kommentar
in die kirche
die kinder sind sie warten auf den
kuchen schon den sie hat gefragt
[Musik]
für ihren nicht existierenden so komm
sag doch was du was raten sie auch schon
ich text nochmal und ja ich überlege man
schafft es doch was sie genommen was hat
sich enorm heute morgen es ist muss ich
sagen noch sehr früh es ist der erste
dreh heute
und deswegen kann ich auch kein
kinderbuch lassen weil ich hatte noch
nicht mal ein frühstück ja ich bin noch
so im schlafmodus verdampfung ja egal
machen wir weiter also da kommt jetzt
die mascarpone dazu statt mascarpone
können die auch quark nehmen oder
frischkäse was kaputt ist einfach super
cremig und passt geschmacklich sogar zu
mild und cremig quark ist er so ein
bisschen säuerlicher passt auch wenn man
so die kombination aus schokolade und
die sind säuerlichen mag und frischkäse
hat zu einem leicht salzigen geschmack
passt aber auch muss man mögen
ich hab ich jetzt für mascarpone djn das
wird jetzt kurz berührt
er gibt ihnen jetzt susanne dazu ganz
langsam
[Musik]
mal auskotzen ist da noch drin hängt
deswegen aktionäre lieber alleine angst
mit mir weil man immer alles auf kraft
gehabt jetzt zum abschlecken hat eine
geschmacksprobe denn ich weiß nicht ob
die süßkraft schon reicht magst du
probieren und du sagst dann ob es genug
wo ist okay also hat eine verantwortung
oder macht das
ich hab nämlich was stimmen gefühl ein
bisschen könnten auch vor allem wenn man
die torte einfällt dann verlierst du so
ein bisschen an geschmack
umsetzungskraft wir stoppen auf gott das
wollte ich wissen
ich habe ja genug eingekauft
sie kann nicht sogar ein bisschen stück
ich lasse für den krampf ist folgendes
zu erstatten
die texte hat sich das stück bin ich mir
mache gerade eine sommer eistorte und in
meinem kopf ist so weihnachten und dann
kann ich es verrühren und mit seiner
partei schlagen
[Musik]
ja okay aus steinen probier laufen
bereits
löffel und probieren oft reicht
schreiben kurz auf und dann schichten
wir schon die torte also es geht echt
mega schnell wie ihr sehen könnt habe
ich hier eine dauer bugdoll ihr könnt
auf backpapier nehmen und lege jetzt
sozusagen die kekse nebeneinander drei
stück da gibt es auch schokokekse aber
die waren grad mich lief aber so schade
also nicht erhältlich ich hab's ja auch
ziemlich liefern lassen
die waren kräftig erhältlich denn ich
denke schokokekse werden nochmal so on
top
das wird perfekter passen und lege ich
jetzt hier noch untereinander
das hat mich jetzt tatsächlich als
lebkuchenhaus bauen
[Musik]
ich habe ziert drei mal sieben ich gucke
jetzt mal ob es passt jetzt kommt
nämlich die creme neben die mit rucksack
ok ja schlecht ich habe so viele hochs
situationen
ich mags selber schon nicht mehr
oh wow ich hatte gerade ein fall meines
lebens ich lege noch in die mitte längst
ein wo er noch ein gott und dann beim
aufschneiden hast du diesen diesen
querschnitts seht ihr so entstehen meine
rezepte in der situation sind überlegt
man beim dreh geht es ja oft so schon so
spontan aber zu bringen wir nicht so ein
backbuch mache da bin ich die ganze zeit
so begeistert weil wenn ich jetzt am
anfang eine zutat nicht zeigt mccarthy
und sagt nichts hast du dir am anfang
nicht gezeigt also muss mir am anfang
schon überlegen was ich mache aber dann
kommt mir währenddessen noch eine coole
idee und im buch da bin ich dann sah und
dies noch und das noch wie viele zimmer
am rezept umschreiben und jetzt hier so
also bittere zeit mehr dass sich die
bürger das nicht gezeigt habe aber es
kommt gleich ein wo in die mitte wo es
so eine sehr ungesunde dort habe ich
schon lange nicht mehr gemacht
aber hätte wird die wird genial so
leicht verteilen okay vielleicht war das
schon zu viel inhalt aber wie es da
war's dann lege ich es einfach quer noch
eine reihe dran
also ist also
denn
[Musik]
können wir sie zum 1
wenn wir uns treffen
ok ich hätte einfach auch wie ich will
ja vorhin schon sagte eine pyramide aus
kinder wo er nun machen können zum essen
oder einfach einfrieren
ich versuche das jetzt hier in der mitte
zu glätten wir gucken einfach was
passiert das gleiche kindern entscheiden
wir wie die form wird es kann sein das
ist schön wie jetzt kann aber auch sein
dass ich eine reihe anbau das entsteht
jetzt da ich so nett bin lasse ich
erschöpfung nach schon möglich aber
wahrscheinlich schrieb eine so der junge
ist ja auch ein ganz süßer und
sympathisch wir fangen schon mehrere
oh wow wow okay wenn das jetzt ganz
ehrlich hier ein paar längen mäßig dann
ist es musste anscheinend so seien es
musste diese fülle und sein denn dieser
länge passt perfekt gut jetzt muss es
noch gut klappen
also das ist ja jetzt nach oben klappen
butterkeks ist gebrochen
da muss ich auch sagen dass die folie
wahrscheinlich besser ist ein spot kommt
hier weil die einfach fester ist jetzt
müsst ihr praktisch so ein bisschen die
creme ok jungstorch doch nichts zum
schmecken sehen dass wahlleiter
perfektes augenmaß es tut mir leid
dafür kriegt später zwei stücke trockels
[Musik]
guck mal hier vorne einfach die creme
nach oben streichen
und jetzt zu klappen wir sind fest sehen
mit spannung und das nehme ich jetzt
[Musik]
es ist schwierig
ok nächste mal macht ist also eher macht
so ihr legt euch gleich was drunter und
fasst damit rechnen ich muss jetzt
leider hier ein bisschen ausbessern
aber da ich die torte einführen werde
hoffe ich geht es zunächst so als sei
oje mini okay ich bis jetzt nur ein und
dann gucken was dabei rauskommt ich
fritz immer ein
also ich habe jetzt die torte im
gefrierschrank aber die gefällt mir
jetzt doch nicht so gut
ihr könnt sie dreieckig machen wir
machen sie auch später fertig auf jeden
fall aber wir dachten uns grad nein nein
wir machen eine runde torte also habe
ich die gleiche creme noch mal
hergestellt und wollt grad schon anfang
in der runde torte zu machen bis mir
einfach ich brauche einen oben also
werde ich jetzt noch ein bisschen butter
holen schmelzen mit den keksen verrühren
und einem no boden machen für den kranz
boden nehme ich mir gesagt butterkekse
etwas butter und kakaopulver und viel wo
er heute morgen dachte ich noch vorhänge
kinder bueno horte exportaktivität
schnell und dann komme ich am ende
halten fünf millionen mal die zutaten
okay die butter mit kurz geschmolzen die
kekse werden verkleinert das machen wir
jetzt alles kurz hier im
schnelldurchgang
[Musik]
obama lege ich jetzt einfach dieses
schmetterlings einfach sein denn damit
kann ich gleich hören programmiert da
draußen habe ich sie schon jetzt alle
kekse reingepasst dass schechter
wahnsinn
verein und der flüssige butter reiten
[Musik]
die creme habe ich übrigens sind
dazwischen zeit in den kühlschrank
gestellt damit sie schön kalt bleibt
ein tipp von meringer kühlen wollen
einfach in den kühlschrank stellen
optisch nur leichte überforderung des
geräts ich muss echt sein das ist sehr
sehr viel masse und es hat geklappt aber
macht bitte nicht nach nicht so viel
inhalt
das ist schon sehr viel
yummy und jetzt kommt es hier direkt in
den tortenring 3
sony war schwach kommt jetzt zum einsatz
die burger fresse ist nämlich der ideale
keks boden zurück und ein glas aber mit
dem geht's einfach schneller
denn erst eine große fläche man hat es
gut in der hand so vor allem finde ich
stand einfach nur mal grund zu sagen
henneberger presse lohnt sich denn ganz
ehrlich wie oft macht mein jahr bürger
jetzt nicht so oft vielleicht gespielt
aber jetzt nicht da kann man dann sagen
hey ich benutze es für süße und
herzhafte gerichte wie schon glatt das
ist und da ist bei mir die butter nicht
mehr warm ist muss ich jetzt auch den
boden nicht kühl stellen das heißt hier
kommt direkt die creme drauf kommt die
creme hier rein und guck mal das jetzt
auch schon fest dass ich werde jetzt
hier noch coeno stücke rhein geben oder
wenn es zu pervers
also nochmal 2 die torte hat irgendwo in
der deluxe und die werde ich so
reingeben mal so kennt man wenn man dann
richtig anschneidet hat man echt so ein
halbes stück lösung
ich hätte gerne dass bei jedem
tortenstück deswegen so ein ziel ich
schon aber ich dann zu arg so ist es
okay das passt jetzt die restliche creme
einfach darüber verteilen und gerne
glattstreichen ich sehe schon vom
geistigen auge wenig die torte später
weitermachen werde
ich bin jetzt aber ehrlich gesagt ein
bisschen hin- und hergerissen ob ich
jetzt die torte abgereist mache ob ich
sie doch nur aus dem kühlschrank
kühlschrank alter wenn ich glaube ich
mache sie nicht komplett eis also nicht
eine geeiste torte
das heißt wenn er sie komplett einfährt
dann ist ja nicht wirklich so eiskalt
aber wenn ihr sie jetzt nur für eine
stunde etwa ins gefrierfach stellt dann
ist es einfach nur weiß dort
bürgermeister kälter als kühlschrank
schön erfrischend und eben trotzdem noch
cremig genug weil eben nicht ganz durch
das worden eine stunde im gefrierschrank
wenn ihr sagt das will ich nicht dann
stellt sich für zwei stunden in den
kühlschrank
ab in die kühlung
[Musik]
also die torte sind gefroren und jetzt
geht es schon an die deko und zwar nehme
ich traf peter kurer türe und von milch
board türe genau so viele frauen wenn
ich eins reicht und die schmelzen wir
auch direkt in einen gefrierbeutel einem
loch im nacken sitzt friedhöfe
mein baby mein baby ist schon so groß
warte erst muss das wasser warm werden
als schwarzes wasser kurz kochen und
schalter aus damit es nicht zu heiß wird
schon gleich und dann machen wir es auch
so gelassen es praktisch schmelzen nicht
komplett vom bisher hat sich der innere
kern bleibt noch fest ich nehme es raus
und durch das markieren wird dann
sozusagen die schokolade temperiert und
ist nicht zu heiß und es regnet es war
so eine schöne eis fordern jetzt regnet
so kommt reicht schon hast recht das
hier ein
gespalten
[Musik]
hierzu lesen wir hier die torte raus das
wirklich so halb geist zu mir und es ist
eine weißt du was ist wenn der tote gibt
das war so dieser moment ich überrasche
das kind und damit sagt das kind mal
schlauer sich lecker lecker lecker
jetzt machen wir folgendes ich stand
hier das manchmal glaubt es gesehen den
ring angestoßen
du weißt doch jetzt holen
tim helwig und ästhetischer rollladen
runter und die spitze weg weil diese
spitze die nervt immer so ein bisschen
und dann erst klein wegschneiden und
gleich die schnipsel weg damit die nicht
in der torte landen
jetzt machen wir so ein bisschen die
beine optisch okay das heißt die
streifen ich sitze auch sagen das war
erstmal nur in eine richtung und dann
gucken wir wie es uns gefällt
ich zeig dir wie kann man ganz kurz mal
nicht in der also nicht in der mitte
anfangen sonst so ein der mitte so einen
klotz das heißt wir fangen immer am rand
an ist echt cool dass du dabei bist man
dann sehe ich was man vielleicht besser
noch besser machen kann als wenn du bist
ja schon froh so ein richtiger produktiv
praktisch hier an und lässt sein so
überlaufen dass wirklich immer so schöne
dünne
dann hat man nicht in der mit dabei wenn
ich jetzt so mache siehst du dann hat
man damit also ein produktion
[Musik]
ich glaube immer hat es doch so wirklich
so kreuz und quer
da machst du die dunkle variante man
immer so zac dünner strich und los genau
und am besten bleibt auf der folie
erspart später viel arbeit
ja super perfekt mein gott ist das wie
bruno oder ok das reicht jetzt schauen
wir mal ob wir die nicht einfach aber
ich habe hier mal so am rand oder aber
das machen wir jetzt so wir setzen erst
mal die torte auf die platte kurz ein
winkel palette
wir machen jetzt teamwork ok und zwar
ich hebe die torte hoch du nimmst das
schiedsrichterteam ihr könnt natürlich
auch einfach das papier darunter
wegziehen und darüber geben aber wir
machen jetzt also besteht die torte hoch
du ziehst das papier weg und die platte
dahin ok hab hier weg sich nicht auf dem
boden
wow macht gleich ein mega unterschied
wenn man so eine torte dann schön
anrichtet also ich finde jetzt schon
wunderschön wirklich die könnten jetzt
auch schon so lassen
ich bin echt gerade auch überlegen
machen wir sie an rand ich glaube nicht
ich glaube wir legen immer so ein stück
oben rein gucken dass wir sozusagen wir
probieren es einfach aus vielleicht
einfach so ein stück so meister so und
dann so hoch oder ich weiß nicht
oder hand angerannt okay was meint ihr
einen kurzen abstimmung
was meinen strom drauf
[Musik]
unter anderen rand
ich würde dem messer das untere kissen
halbieren das ist genau an der kante
dann ist open dass es nicht raus steht
sondern an den rand julia ich probier's
mal ich probier's mal mit dem messer mit
dem rand weil ich finde es auch am
randstein also jemand nicht mehr so
viele buenos wir müssen glaube ich
nochmal kaufen
die sind in der anderen torte
sieht schon gut aus das problem ist nur
dass wir jetzt praktisch immer die rammt
stücke brauchen
das hätte ich mir also das kann sich
echt vorher tatsächlich überlegen dann
schneidet immer nummer eins und das
halben und den rest der praktisch der
verschnitt den verschnitt nehmt ihr dann
für die creme
so kann man es machen weil ich hätte
jetzt schon gern hier oben immer die
geschlossene seite das heißt warte
marathon hat man immer hier
es hat die mitte oder gucken es aushält
nehmen vielleicht noch die mitte so
dazwischen
nein jetzt schon was man sieht schon gut
aus
ok kann kurz jemand buena taufen so
jetzt keine mehr auf essen ja weil ich
musste jetzt auch abwägen damit das
rezept schreiben kann damit dass dann
gleich passt von der menge weil ich muss
jetzt schon dazu sagen also das hätte
ich mir jetzt wirklich überlegen kann
aber wie gesagt ich schreibe euch dann
einfach in das rezept in die app wie wie
viele ihr braucht denn ihr braucht keine
sieben packungen und dann nehmt ihr
einfach am anfang die point ausschneidet
wirklich für die deko diese zurecht und
diesen verschnitt den nehmen wir für die
creme okay dann passt das 0 4 packung
[Musik]
wenn jetzt noch die tortenplatte
gewechselt denn die war einfach zu klein
mit dem rand also eigentlich durchmesser
gepasst aber leider entschuldige
hast du da was weg genau jetzt passt es
und jetzt leben war einfach die bonus
hier an den rand und dann ist sie fertig
und kann fotografiert werden und danach
dürft ihr zwei probieren okay wir
seitdem de kuchen tester wenn ihr
möchtet ihr
[Musik]
du gibst mir nochmal 2
ich glaube es reicht
[Musik]
so wie gefällt euch die torte mir auch
perfekt sitze aus ok weißt du was wir
tauschen doch die zwei hier aus denn die
sind so ein bisschen angeblichen davert
unten
aber wir nach schon jetzt nichts mehr
wir warten jetzt auf die torte also bis
gleich zum probieren
[Musik]
da hast du genau
sagst du die wahrheit was durch das darf
man aber nicht immer muss immer die
wahrheit sagen hast du gedacht okay aber
jetzt reicht's gehen
[Musik]
probieren wir mal was er geleistet hat
ich probiere von jens okay ist
[Musik]
heller probiert natürlich ein boeing und
der stoff ausprobieren
probieren wir haben schon die
komponenten probiert aber komba die hier
kommt noch der noten no basecape diese
kleider sind wahrscheinlich ja warte ich
schon ok cache spezialist und guck mal
da innen drin hat sich versteckt dass
kinder bueno keine bananen
die lakers haben auch die konsistenz
erinnert so und banane also auf jeden
fall unbedingt nachmachen die dreieckige
torte haben jetzt leider auch noch übrig
also j leider gibt's heute noch mehr
kuchen
das heißt wir können mit allen teilen
aber ich finde die version echt die
besten also probiert unbedingt aus
postert ein foto und viel spaß beim
nachmachen bis zum nächsten mal
ich darf das ganze haben auch die user
aus jetzt sagt sie so ich habe doch der
rest
[Musik]